A Pacman-shaped ukelele, and heavy metal t-shirt.
It's episode 13 of Lüt.
This is a ticking time bomb.
The longer you wait, the more pieces will
wind up soggy- except, with the Obol, you
decide what pieces get wet, and when.
And these wine glasses let you control wet
stuff, musically.
The markings on the side tell you where to
fill for a specific note when running your
finger over the rim.
Luna and Curious offer Bonny tights with a
hidden gun, and socks that make you look like
a duck.
But, for you men, if you want to look classy
and upcycled, check out these ties.
They're made out of wood from demolished barns.
They're also a perfect companion to these
No-Wash underpants.
The front's yellow, the back's brown.
No worries.
But if you do plan on practicing some hygiene,
do it in the dark with this glow-in-the-dark
toilet paper from Firebox.
Now, if things get smelly but you want to
maintain manliness, use a Man Can.
These candles smell like bacon, sawdust, new
york style pizza, a new leather baseball mitt,
and more.
Ok, the classic Coca-Cola bottle shape- please.
I prefer the original Hutchinson can.
As part of their 125th anniversary you can
own the bottle's entire history.
Now, if you like heat and sweet, drizzle spicy,
chili pepper-infused Hot Honey on your pizza.
They even say it goes well in tea.
Stay fancy with Think Geek's science jewelry:
A pendant that is also a functioning sun dial,
and this 8-bit hair bow.
Then play a game of poker with some toast
playing cards, the Joker's are eaten and burnt.
Japan Trend Shop also carries this desk desk
lamp suspended by its spill.
Then, relax in this replica Big Lebowski "The
Dude" cardigan.
The one used in the movie auctioned for more
than $10,000, but, now, the company that originally
made it is offering a replica for $188.
You can wear it and lounge around listening
to your iPhone or iPod in a nice, loud gramophone
station.
Not sticky enough?
Well, try out NeatoShop's phone stand that
looks like bubble gum, and be sure to use
the Kick To Pick app that balances on a pregnant
belly, cycles through possible baby names,
and uses the phone's accelerometer to detect
baby kicks so that your baby can choose its
own name before it's even born.
Transfer files with these fried shrimp USB
memory sticks, or a super-slim bookmark that
is also a 2 GB flashdrive.
Now it's time for something free: The font
that Coca-Cola is written in.
It's just the way people used to be taught
how to do cursive back at the turn of the
century.
It's called Spencerian Handwriting, and it
was replaced later on by the Palmer Method
which, for instance, Mickey Mantle used.
And, today, we learn the D'Nealian Method.
But, anyway, what that means is that Coca-Cola
obviously owns the trademark to their brand
name, "Coca-Cola", but they don't own the
copyright on the specific script it's written
in.
I mean, for crying out loud, the Ford Motor
Company used the same script.
So, there you go.
Have fun using your free, public domain ancient-cursive
style, and, as always, thanks for watching.